I'm with a very very special person
today my son Mac Mac let's say hi
everybody
[Music]
now like most parents we've had to get
creative to keep the little ones busy
and what better way to do that then a
dance party like they have parties bob
is the number one at Music Brantford
kids we take all the most popular songs
nowadays and we make them kid-friendly
here's what these kids do they cover
pops biggest hits but without mature
subject matter like sex or alcohol
Chrissy Teigen had no idea Kidz Bop even
changed the lyrics to John's ballad all
of me
[Music]
how do you feel about that I mean a big
sense I'm down I'm obviously down for a
lyric chicken that squeaky-clean formula
makes serious money and has a celebrity
following let me have it in the car all
the time your kids a fan yes just how
popular are they Kidz Bop has sold more
than 20 million albums worldwide and
generated more than 3 billion streams
their US tours alone if sold more than
half a million tickets for alums like
zendaya it can also be a career
launching point but the fun won't last
forever Kidz Bop kids have to be between
the ages of 9 and 12 every few years
they replace the kids every kid 12 kids
that has been the Kidz Bop is a part of
our family
[Music]